Os voy a hacer una pregunta ¿Qué ideología
tiene Vladimir Putin? ¿Es de izquierdas o
de derechas? En el vídeo de hoy vamos a repasar
esta y muchas otras claves para entender a este
hombre. Vamos a decirlo claro: este año 2022
tiene dos protagonistas claros; Vladimir Putin
y Volodymir Zelensky - tranquilos, que el vídeo
sobre Zelensky le publicaremos dentro de poco.
Y, por cierto, aquí os doy un dato curioso:
ambos políticos tienen el mismo nombre. Es
decir, Volodymyr es Vladimir en ucraniano.
Si sois veteranos seguidores de VisualPolitik,
ya sabéis que tenemos una tradición navideña
que cumplimos todos los años: los premios y los
antipremios VisualPolitik. Es decir, dedicamos
un vídeo a los que nos parecen que han sido los
3 mejores políticos del año… y otro con los
peores. Normalmente nos cuesta mucho preparar
esta lista y nos pasamos días discutiendo.
Y este año, además, teníamos una obligación:
teníamos que destacar a Zelensky, que ya tiene
un premio VisualPolitik, y también a Putin,
un tipo que pese a no esperar gran cosa de él…
Ha superado nuestras expectativas… Para mal.
Esto estaba tan claro que al final hemos
decidido dedicarles un vídeo entero a cada uno.
Y ya sé lo que pensaréis muchos ¿Otro vídeo
sobre Putin? ¡Llevamos todo el año escuchando las
barbaridades de este hombre! ¿Qué más se puede
contar de Putin que no sepamos? Seamos claros:
desde el punto de vista ético, Putin merece todos
los antipremios y condenas posibles. Ahora bien,
hasta hace pocos meses, todos los
analistas reconocían su visión
estratégica. Podría ser malo, pero no era tonto.
Ahora bien, después de todos los errores que ha
cometido en Ucrania, no está tan claro que sea
semejante genio del mal como algunos podrían
pensar. Por eso, en el vídeo de hoy vamos a
centrarnos en la biografía de Putin ¿Quién
es Vladimir Putin? ¿Qué legado político quiere
dejar? ¿En qué medida sus experiencias vitales
han influido en su ideología política?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas,
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de historia.
T1(DE LA KGB AL CIELO DE MOSCÚ)
Desde que llegó al poder, Vladimir Putin ha
querido hacerse ver como un hombre fuerte,
capaz en el imaginario colectivo incluso
de cazar a un tigre con sus propias manos
o de doblegar a un oso en una lucha a muerte.
Pero, ¿y si os dijera que el ex agente del KGB
no era tan importante ni imponente como lo es
hoy? La realidad, amigos de VisualPolitik, es
que no fue ninguna especie de James Bond ruso.
En realidad, se parecía más a un funcionario de
los que están en una oficina haciendo números.
Absolutamente lo opuesto al clásico político
mesiánico que hemos conocido después.
Putin nació, en el año 1952,
en la ciudad más liberal de toda la antigua
Unión Soviética, Leningrado - lo que hoy es
San Petersburgo. A diferencia de Zelensky,
Putin se crió en una familia obrera. Y aquí
viene una de las grandes claves de su vida: su
padre era un convencido comunista y su madre,
una ferviente cristiana ortodoxa. Tan religiosa
era esta mujer, que decidió bautizar a su hijo en
secreto, incluso sin que lo supiera el padre.
Es decir, que su alma estaba dividida desde
su niñez. Y esto ha marcado la ideología
de Putin hasta nuestros días. De hecho,
atentos a una de sus citas más recordadas.
C1( “Quien no lamenta la desaparición de la
Unión Soviética no tiene corazón. Quien
quiera restaurarla no tiene cerebro.
Vladimir Putin. 20 de febrero, 2000.”)
Sin embargo, durante su juventud,
Putin fue todo un patriota de la Unión Soviética.
Por eso, tan pronto como terminó sus estudios,
en 1975, ingresó en la KGB. Para quien no lo sepa,
la KGB era la agencia de inteligencia soviética:
el equivalente a la CIA. Aquí es donde
suele comenzar el mito de Putin como un
héroe de la nación comprometido con
sus compatriotas y la madre Rusia.
Estoy seguro de que muchos de vosotros habréis
escuchado que Putin fue muy importante en el
servicio de inteligencia soviético. Y todos
nos hemos imaginado alguna vez a una especie de
James Bond versión comunista. Pero la realidad
es bastante menos espectacular. En realidad,
la mayor parte del trabajo de un espía
es... ¡Trabajo de oficina! De hecho,
Putin se encargaba principalmente de reclutar
a informantes. Le destinaron a las oficinas de
Alemania del Este, que por entonces era una
colonia de la URSS. Viviendo en Berlín Este,
Putin vivió uno de los acontecimientos más
importantes de la historia reciente. Algo que le
obligó a replantearse sus convicciones comunistas.
En 1989, los alemanes derribaron el muro de
Berlín. 3 años más tarde, Putin
volvió a su ciudad natal mientras
el presidente de la Unión Soviética, Mikhail
Gorvachov, anunciaba el fin del comunismo.
Como os podéis imaginar, todo esto supuso
un shock para los valores que Putin había
defendido durante años en la KGB. Eso explica
que renunciara a su puesto y se metiera en la
política. Empezó asesorando al primer
alcalde elegido democráticamente en San
Petersburgo. Su primer trabajo fue buscar
inversores internacionales para la ciudad.
(El ascenso al poder de Putin comenzó
justamente aquí, al lograr mantener a
los oligarcas bien atados. Así, en 1998 se hizo
con el poder del Servicio Federal de Seguridad,
la antigua KGB. Por entonces, ya era
un jerifalte de un partido político.)
Sin embargo, el segundo shock ideológico llegó
en 1998 ¿Qué pasó ese año? Fue cuando Putin
perdió a su madre. Si recordáis, la madre de
Putin era una ferviente cristiana. Pues bien,
en su lecho de muerte, le regaló un crucifijo. Y,
por lo que dicen los biógrafos, desde entonces,
nunca se lo ha quitado. Este fue el
momento donde Putin renovó su fe. Y,
creedme, esto es algo mucho más importante de
lo que parece. Pero eso lo veremos más adelante.
Con su fe renovada, en 1999
Yeltsin ya estaba allanando
el camino para la toma del poder de
Putin. Y, a principios de ese año,
le nombró Primer Ministro y, más
tarde, Presidente en funciones.
Tras la dimisión de Yeltsin y la convocatoria de
elecciones, Putin se convirtió en Presidente de
Rusia de manera absoluta. Ganó las elecciones
del año 2000 con más de un 50% de los votos.
Yeltsin le había dado al pueblo un nuevo líder
a quien seguir. Pero os estaréis preguntando,
¿cómo un tipo como Putin, que mucha gente temía
incluso dentro del país, llegó al poder? Esto se
explica por dos sencillas razones: la promesa de
una economía mejor después de la crisis de 1998,
y su firmeza frente al terrorismo checheno
- recordemos que Chechenia es un territorio
turbulento para Rusia, con aspiraciones
independentistas que terminaron en una
dura confrontación militar con Moscú.- Putin iba a
ser el hombre fuerte y decidido que Rusia quería.
Putin prometía aires de renovación en el país,
pero era consciente de que gran parte de su
población echaba de menos a la Unión Soviética.
No extrañan entonces medidas como restaurar con
algunos cambios en la letra el himno de la URSS
como himno nacional o usar la bandera de la
Unión Soviética para eventos militares.
¿Ahora entendéis, queridos amigos de
VisualPolitik, por qué en Ucrania se ven
tanques rusos con banderas soviéticas?.
Pero, más allá de todo simbolismo, ¿qué ha
hecho realmente Putin? ¿En qué cree exactamente?
T2(CAPITALISMO A LA PUTIN)
Si recordáis, Putin estuvo
destinado en la Alemania comunista
con el KGB hasta que cayó el muro
de Berlín. Vivió en sus propias carnes las
ineficiencias de la administración soviética:
funcionarios corruptos, gente sin talento
que llega al poder por favores políticos y
una espiral de errores que llevaron
al colapso final. Desde entonces,
Putin tiene claro que el comunismo no funciona.
C2(“El comunismo y el poder de los soviet no
hicieron de Rusia un país próspero con una
sociedad en desarrollo dinámico y un pueblo
libre.” Declaración política Rusia en
el cambio de siglo. Vladimir Putin.)
Vamos, que con Putin estaba claro que no habría
una vuelta al comunismo. Pero claro, el sistema
que había heredado de Yeltsin tampoco era
demasiado eficiente. Entonces, ¿qué creéis que
hizo? Si sois fieles seguidores de VisualPolitik
seguro que lo habéis adivinado: ¡un capitalismo a
la Putin! Y, ¿cómo lo construyó? Usando a unos
viejos conocidos del canal: ¡los silovikis! Si
recordáis, los silovikis son políticos y altos
funcionarios del gobierno con una larga carrera
en los servicios de seguridad del país. Por
ejemplo: Serguéi Ivanov o Serguéi Shoigú fueron
sus antiguos compañeros de trabajo. Y aquí
quiero que hagamos una reflexión interesante.
Para Putin, el problema del comunismo no
es la economía centralizada sino los malos
gestores. Cuando Yeltsin intentó su transición
al capitalismo, se rodeó de oligarcas con poca
formación, y... en muchos casos, con adicciones de
todo tipo. Por eso, la gran apuesta de Putin fue
sustituir a los malos gestores por gente con ideas
firmes, mano dura y buen curriculum. Este es el
principio básico del capitalismo de los silovikis.
Y diréis ¿Funcionó el capitalismo al
estilo Putin? Pues, en principio,
parecería que sí. Fijaos en esta gráfica.
Desde que Putin llegó al poder en el año 2000,
¡la economía rusa creció sin interrupción hasta
el 2008! De hecho, los salarios de los rusos
incluso se duplicaron. Seguro que la mayoría
sabéis por qué. ¡Exacto! Rusia es una potencia
energética. En un momento donde el gas y el
petróleo tenían precios altos, Rusia vivió una
luna de miel. La economía iba viento en popa
y logró ajustar todas las cuentas del Estado.
Pero fuera como fuera el tiempo parecía darle
la razón a Putin. Su receta económica no se
basaba en crear unas instituciones fuertes
sino en poner a “buenos” gestores
en los puestos de decisión.
Y diréis ¿Esto es todo? ¿Esto es todo lo que
podemos decir de la ideología de Putin? Pues no.
Hay mucho más. Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T3(¿EUROPA Y ASIA UNIDAS?)
Está claro que para entender a Putin no hay que
leer a Marx. Tampoco a Hayek ni a Adam Smith.
Los grandes referentes intelectuales de Putin
son autores rusos prácticamente desconocidos
en Occidente. Autores como IVAN ILLYN, YEVGENI
PRIMAKOV o ALEXANDER DUGIN. Y esto nos lleva
a hablar de una ideología de la que muy
pocos habréis oído hablar: el eurasianismo.
Básicamente, el eurasianismo defiende
la creación de un bloque cultural entre
Europa y Asia en contra de lo que sería
un bloque anglo-americano. Por supuesto,
todo esto se puede traducir en una frase:
restablecer el imperio colonial ruso. Pero,
para los euroasiáticos, todo esto tiene
una justificación mucho más profunda.
Y, ¿cómo se traduce esto a
la política? Vamos a verlo.
(Putin sigue una especie de versión actualizada de
los 5 puntos que el Primer Ministro ruso de 1993,
Yevgeni Primakov, siguió: el primero es
la defensa de la posición de Rusia como
potencia mundial y no solo regional; el segundo
lo que se conoce como el pragmatismo racional;
tercero la asociación con China como piedra
angular de la política exterior rusa;
el cuarto la oposición a cualquier expansión
de la OTAN y los vínculos con aquellos países
que quieran luchar contra la hegemonía de
Estados Unidos; y, el quinto, que Rusia
utilice su poderío nuclear y su poder de veto en
el Consejo de Seguridad de las Naciones Unidas.)
De hecho, la versión actualizada, el
NEOEURASIANISMO de ALEXANDER DUGIN ve
a tres países específicos que podrían ayudar
a Rusia a liderar el proyecto euroasiático:
Alemania, para controlar Europa; Irán, para
estrechar lazos con los países árabes y Japón,
para controlar Asia; ya que Dugin tampoco
se fía mucho de las futuras pretensiones
imperialistas de China. Esta es la teoría.
Y os preguntaréis, ¿por qué Putin quiere
formar un bloque euroasiático? Bueno,
si recordáis, el NEOEURASIANISMO quiere
arrancar de las garras del tío Sam la
policía del mundo. Dicho de otra forma,
Putin defiende un orden mundial multipolar
en contraposición a la hegemonía indiscutible
de Estados Unidos ¿Y cuáles serían esos
polos? Pues Eurasia - bajo el mando ruso,
claro- , China y Estados Unidos. Vamos, que Putin
defiende la esencia del eurasianismo, que se
puede resumir en lo siguiente, atentos:
C3(“Rusia debería recuperar el estatus de
gran potencia y convertirse en un centro de
oposición al unilateralismo estadounidense
en la política mundial.”
– Emre Ersen, doctor en la
Universidad de Marmara. 2004
¿Y cómo puede recuperar ese
estatus Rusia? Por supuesto, uno de
sus pilares es un ejército fuerte.
Eso explica la modernización del ejército
que se llevó a cabo en la década de 2010
¡Pero no sólo eso!
Para convertirse en
una potencia hegemónica, Rusia necesitaba
poder blando. Y eso nos lleva a la DOCTRINA
KARAGANOV. Este término que parece sacado
de una película es uno de los instrumentos
principales de Putin para justificar sus
invasiones ¿En qué consiste? Muy simple:
en hacer de Rusia la protectora de
todas las personas étnicamente rusas
que viven en los países del alrededor,
incluso aunque tengan otra nacionalidad.
Esto puede suponer incluso dar pasaportes rusos
a las poblaciones de territorios de otros países.
Y así es como luego se puede justificar
la intervención del ejército ¡En teoría,
están defendiendo a sus compatriotas!.
Por eso esto se conoce también como
“política de los compatriotas”.
¿Pero es Putin el líder euroasiático
perfecto? ¡Ni mucho menos! En política, una cosa
es la teoría y otra la práctica. Por ejemplo,
durante la Guerra de Afganistán, Putin permitió
que Estados Unidos estableciera bases militares
en Asia Central. Esto le hizo ganar todo tipo de
críticas entre la línea dura del eurasianismo.
Sin embargo, aunque no sea el líder euroasiático
perfecto, es realmente el único en la región
ahora mismo. Su objetivo sigue siendo el mismo:
que Estados Unidos no tenga tanto poder y que
Rusia restablezca su honor. Pero para ello
necesita algo más que debilitar al tío Sam,
necesita crear una identidad euroasiática. ¿Y
cómo quiere Putin hacer esto? Pues atentos.
T4(IN PUTIN WE TRUST)
¿Recordáis que Putin se reafirmó en la fé ortodoxa
a la muerte de su madre? Pues esto no es sólo una
anécdota. La llegada de Putin al poder trajo un
cambio radical en la manera en que se trataba a la
religión en Rusia. De hecho, su pilar maestro
para la identidad euroasiática es, nada más y nada
menos, que la Iglesia Ortodoxa. Paraos a pensar
por un momento: la Unión Soviética era un estado
ateo: la religión estaba perseguida, incluida la
ortodoxa. Sin embargo, aunque la Unión Soviética
aplastase a la religión en su territorio, no
mataron la fe. De hecho, hoy más del 70% de
la población en Rusia es cristiana ortodoxa.
Por eso, la Iglesia Ortodoxa es una figura
clave para el proyecto euroasiático. A
fin de cuentas, si quieres invadir países,
necesitas algo más que armas. También tienes que
construir una identidad nacional. Y para eso,
la religión es fundamental. Y diréis ¿Pero
todo esto cómo se traduce en políticas reales?
Una de las primeras políticas de Putin fue bajar
los impuestos a la Iglesia Ortodoxa. En Rusia,
las iglesias no están exentas de pagar impuestos.
Además, en 2010, el Kremlin devolvió todas
las propiedades que los comunistas habían
incautado a los religiosos ¡Pero no sólo eso!
Putin ha permitido que la Iglesia obtenga grandes
beneficios de las empresas energéticas. Todo esto
ha supuesto una inyección de capital enorme para
los popes ortodoxos. Gracias a eso, han podido
construir más de 23.000 nuevas iglesias.
En otras palabras: mientras el resto de
Europa es cada vez más secular,
Rusia va en la dirección opuesta.
¡Pero no sólo hablamos de dinero! También
hablamos de cultura. Por ejemplo, en 2012
introdujo la asignatura de ortodoxia en todas
las escuelas públicas. Y en 2016 introdujo la
Ley YAROVAYA, que permite al Estado reprimir
a las comunidades religiosas minoritarias como
la protestante para que no evangelicen a rusos.
¿Y qué le ha dado la Iglesia Ortodoxa a cambio? Lo
habéis adivinado: un apoyo incondicional en
todas las campañas de expansión rusa. En 2014,
cuando Rusia apoyó a los secesionistas en
la parte este de Ucrania, en el Donbás,
la Iglesia sirvió como un aparato de propaganda
masiva. En todas las iglesias ortodoxas se
defendían los intereses del Kremlin. Y esta
lealtad llega hasta nuestros días. Atentos.
N1(“El patriarca Kiril llama a los rusos a
la “movilización espiritual” – Agencia EFE,
27 de septiembre de 2022.)
De hecho, el patriarca de la Iglesia Ortodoxa rusa
ha llegado a decir que la guerra purificaría el
alma de todo aquel que cayera en combate. Fijaos:
C4(“La Iglesia es consciente de que si alguien
(...) muere en el cumplimiento del deber militar,
entonces indudablemente (...) se sacrifica
por los demás. Este sacrificio lava todos
los pecados que una persona ha
cometido" – Patriarca Kiril.)
Y la pregunta es ¿Hasta qué punto Putin
está consiguiendo este sueño euroasiático?
Pues tenemos que reconocer
que, hasta este año 2022,
estaba dando pasos importantes
en esta dirección. Por ejemplo,
en 2014 culminó uno de los proyectos clave del
eurasianismo: la Unión Económica Euroasiática.
Esta Unión junta solamente a 5 países: a Rusia,
por supuesto, con Bielorrusia, Kazajistán,
Kirguistán y Armenia. El año pasado le dedicamos
un vídeo entero a esta unión, que podría ser
la versión rusa de la Unión Europea: libertad
de personas, capitales y bienes entre estos 5
países ¿El problema? El problema es que la Guerra
de Ucrania ha puesto todo esto en entredicho. Uno
de los países más importantes de esta unión es
Kazajistán, que cada vez se está alejando más
de la órbita rusa. Pero de eso ya hemos
hablado largo y tendido en otros vídeos.
Pero ahora las preguntas son para vosotros, ¿Será
la guerra de Ucrania un golpe definitivo para el
proyecto euroasiático de Putin? Y si ganara la
guerra, ¿sería esto un impulso? ¿No temerían
sus socios euroasiáticos a la madre Rusia si no
estuvieran de acuerdo con Putin? Podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios. Como
siempre, no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. Un saludo y hasta pronto.